début juillet alors qu'elle n'avait rien
demandé nadia reçoit une petite
enveloppe met lass est estampillé china
post et y avait deux mentions amazon
mais tout le reste du texte était
vraisemblablement d'arrêt à l'intérieur
des semences de tomates ou de poivrons
c'est pas clair quelques semaines plus
tard un [ __ ] sur facebook j'ai vu
j'avais d'autres amis qui avait reçu en
fait l'agencé canadienne d'inspection
des aliments a déjà reçu environ 400
signalement ils se comptent par milliers
aux états unis à face à bague c'est le
département de l'agriculture a pour
l'instant identifié une douzaine de
semences de la lavande du romarin de
l'amante de l'hibiscus rien de méchant à
priori même sens la référence à superman
les autorités canadiennes sont tout
aussi prudente elle pourrait envahir des
zones agricoles et naturels causé de
graves dommages à nos ressources
végétales et à notre environnement
elle ne pousseront pas dans le jardin de
nadia qui préfèrent surtout se demander
pourquoi elles ont été envoyées ce
serait une fraude qui permet à
l'entreprise de s'écrire un avis positif
pour chaque envoi effectuer tout d'un
coup votre compagnie reçoit des milliers
et des milliers vous avez créé des
milliers des milliers de comptes qui
tousse évalue vos services de façon
extrêmement positif ce qui veut dire que
dans un service de livraison en ligne
comme amazon com rouge etc
vous allez donc probablement être dans
les compagnies fiable qui ont eu
énormément de revue positive et donc
d'augmenter sa visibilité et ses ventes
quant à la liste d'envoi elle provient
vraisemblablement d'un vol de données
en attendant les résultats de son
enquête l'agencé canadienne d'inspection
des aliments demande à chaque personne
qui a reçu un paquet de graines de
prendre contact avec un bureau régional
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal